a lot has been said about the Ukrainian
offensive how is it going now it's a
couple of weeks into it have they gained
much ground
yes and thanks for having me on Kimberly
they've gained a significant amount of
territory in the uh the period since the
account defense have started now it
started on the 29th of August although
conditions had been set prior to that
with some strikes uh strategic strikes
in Crimea against um an Airfield and
some logistical Supply hubs what have
you since then they've been put though
they announced the offensive on the 29th
of August they've been pushing uh from
the hairson area targeting Bridge
Crossings across the nepro river so
cutting off the supply lines of the
Russians in that area on the on the
Western Bank of the river and they're
slowly pushing forward at a realistic
pace and the Russians are conducting a
controlled withdrawal from the area to
come back uh probably onto the Eastern
Bank of the Negro River what we then saw
in the sort of the second week of
September is that the second front the
counteroffensive up in the north around
the kahi or Hakeem area where the the
Russians were controlling the main
supply lines coming down from belgarod
uh down to the South where the main
fighting was taking place in Islam so if
we could move on to to the next slide
there we go so from the um the around
about the eighth and 9th of September
the Ukrainian forces started pushing
away from car keeps forcing the Russians
back over into the border into Russia
itself cutting off those vital supply
lines coming down from belga Rod to
Islam and pushing the Russian forces
back to the the oskill river which is a
natural obstacle which is them dividing
the the forces there so they've taken a
considerable amount of territory in what
was really quite a fast pace of time
where two or two to three days what
we're seeing now is a more realistic
pace of the the county offensive taking
place the ukrainians have managed to
establish a small Bridgehead onto the
Eastern Bank of the oskill river and
we're now seeing they've liberated is um
which was a key time they needed to take
the name pushing towards Lyman which
will open up a corridor and allowing
them to push forward towards Little
chance and severeign course they lost to
the Russians in July of this year yeah
let's talk about these referenda that
we've been reporting on all day
they're being held in certain regions
how are they going about them
well the the referendum are taking place
in in the Hearthstone oblast uh zaparita
Donetsk and the luhansko blast uh
obviously Done Yet is going to Hans form
up the donbass region which was the
stated aim of President Putin to to take
and liberate those to be part of Russia
because the Russian people there so the
referendums are taking place like most
likely been rushed forward in in
response to the counter-offensive so the
the Russians can claim the territory
before it's taken over by the ukrainians
now what we're seeing happening in in
these areas is residents are being
obstructed from leaving the areas there
are incentives for for the citizens to
pass on their personal details in
exchange for humanitarian Aid and that's
likely for the Russians to get their
details for falsification of voting
records we're also seeing or having
reports
um within the some of the the regions of
young children from the age of 13 to 17
have been able to vote as well and we're
seeing in Russia itself polling stations
are being set up by the the directional
authorities in the areas where people
were forcibly relocated as a result of
the war from from these controlled areas
and again they're going to be able to
vote or they're being forced to vote in
those areas and highly likely that the
results will be falsified in order to
have a the Sham referendum and produce
the results which will most likely
result in a vote to Annex those
territories into Russia properly but the
problem we have is particularly
zapparicha and Donetsk the Russians
don't actually control all of those
oblasts there's still a lot of those
areas are controlled by the ukrainians
so if they get annexed them they're in
the the position where they're trying to
control something which they don't
actually have any presence in